I'm David Freeman I'm Christie and we're
from [ __ ] Georgia I got into law
enforcement about four years ago the
camaraderie is there I love the guys
that work with this is my office this is
where I spend 12 hours a day
generally when most people see me I look
like this we were both raised not to go
into debt but I don't feel like we had a
good plan on how we do it finances was
not a priority it just kind of went
downhill pretty quickly we decided that
we were gonna go through financial piece
and that's when we partnered with parky
Thompson well I met with them one night
on a Wednesday evening with their small
group and the following morning I met
with Dave and Christie to talk about
their finance isn't exactly what was
going on there and so over the next
several months we began a working
relationship in one of my programs to
help them make the changes that they
needed to make with their finances it
was the first time in 12 years of
marriage that we really figured out how
to do it right I was at home from work
and just checking on some news and so
forth the news popped up with a bulletin
breaking news tonight an officer shot
multiple times and immediately my heart
sunk that Alfred a police officer has
been shot the Alpharetta police officer
pulled over a black Isuzu the truck here
on Main Street for a tag violation it
was just a few minutes later where I got
an email from a mutual friend part of
that small group that they had to pray
for David that he had actually been shot
in the line of duty they say as soon as
the officer walked up to the truck
the driver opened fire I made it up to
about his the rear tire of his car his
truck
and he opened up his car door and got
out he already had the gun in his hand
and was turning towards me and started
shooting and I remember seeing a couple
of his bullets skip off the ground and
there was something inside me they just
said it's not happened this way today
I'm not going down like this I was able
to return fire him I got about nine
shots off at him and at that point I
didn't realize I was shot I went to
reload my gun I look down and I could
see the holes of my shirt I was like oh
this isn't good by that point the
Calvary was coming and it is the
sweetest sound to hear lights and sirens
coming
so I wasn't sure what was happening to
me and I leaned over to the firefighter
that was with me because he stayed by my
side the entire time I said hey I need
to call him leave a message on your cell
phone for my kids and for my wife he
looked at me and he said no this is your
vitals are good I think we're good a
friend of our she's a captain he came to
get me and I got picked up get her to
the hospital and it really was the way I
did the best way I describe it was like
I was watching a movie that I was a part
of but I really wasn't it wasn't me it
was like I was watching an actress be a
part of it because you know we're pretty
normal people pretty average all she
kept talking about was that she had an
emergency fund and all I have is it well
least I got an emergency fund he's like
put but he's laying on the ER table and
all she's talking about is this
emergency fund and I don't know but yeah
I think that's how I was coping like I
just again I was in do mode so the
finances were in place and I think it
was my way of not thinking about what
was actually happening to him at the
moment
yeah shot in the leg the stomach twice
in my right hip my right shoulder and
twice at my elbow the doctors literally
sat there like this and he said I cannot
figure out how you're alive the fact is
emergencies happen to people all the
time and being prepared for those is
what's key and so as a coach and helping
them and helping others is to focus and
realize we are not exempt from that none
of us are guarantee that everything's
gonna be perfect our lives changed
dramatically overnight
I could imagine what that would have
looked like if we had not had a plan if
we had not really gotten ourselves on
track now that we're getting back and
getting back in the swing of things our
plan would be hitting that debt snowball
as hard as we can we saw on the road
ahead of us we're choosing to continue
to work hard at you know it at making
our lives better financially despite
everything that's happened
you
you